and you are nice to meet you
I grew up in East LA yes all right so
how much of that again we're metal
traitor
he's lost everybody knows what a tree
when I was 14
I go up with about 40 house of my own I
ended up be on my own
guests say
this well I had a dysfunctional family
that's for sure but when I was younger I
grew up but I had both my parents but my
dad even till the Thank You solar colic
growing up here the alcoholic my mom she
was into drugs you know my dad to the
parent used to be swinger parenting
that's kind of like I don't know they
don't you know I mean 14 trying to I
guess look for love and acceptance now
but I found it in my neighborhood in my
neighborhood I met a few people and just
I was always the one who said I never
wanted to be from hood - no - like to
have to show nobody where I'm from or
dead I'm down for mine because I just
handle stuff right when things happen
because the best way to do it you know
that just shows that I'm not a [ __ ] ass
like I don't put me at she's not gonna
like you know nobody can tell me what to
do
I just I mean I'm not a dumb person I
know right from wrong and I know like
morally my beliefs and what I stand for
so like so when it comes to my hair
place that's like that mean you know
[Music]
I never betrayed
like three prison terms
for robbery first and then
home invasion and I have two cars I sell
fine I guess nobody ever says that you
know like that's something they want a
girl doing is just stuff happened [ __ ]
happens you know life happens and for
gang members like guess it's just it's
not a choice like you just do what you
got to do what no matter what for your
family for you for your brothers and
sisters you know like you're good this
is a female game ever pretty different
um they are a lot and waste like the
especially back back way back but like
now it's more like we have to [ __ ] be
as good we have to be as hard or as
ready they're like to bus the catwalks
over they almost like just to you gotta
just be quick to be a killer and it's
but that's everyday life you know I mean
like we're I can't where I grew up where
and where I come from like that's just
that's automatic it's like in your basic
tools for life you know like number one
to survival and
you're a shark are you comfy as I know
that if it gets down to your me it's not
gonna be me don't say that
do I dance with the devil on a daily
basis yes paying with my life period is
some ballsy thing you know but it's a
ballsy thing to have to live through the
life that we have to live through in
today's times and I don't know like
don't let me ride what I have or what I
do how I react it's a part of my
environment you know like like just be
in prison and you know we heard that a
baby case was coming up and a lot of
times we don't it's not in me to just be
like all [ __ ] week I'll plug the
[ __ ] cuz I know I kinda know that
wasn't raised like that and my head
didn't raise me like that like there's
there's older one with it
that sat me down you know like when I go
jump just whenever it was
when I got jumped into my head by 14 I
got jumped in by two guys and two girls
and I don't mean nothing if you're a guy
you you're gonna you know check that I'm
gonna go check it right now and I can
you know if I can give it to her just
the same way but I let her it's been
like noubar he would so like everybody's
treated the same in that aspect but like
when it comes to said we have ethics and
codes when it comes to thanks - we don't
you're not supposed to like you know we
get cheque or we could get we can't even
get a green light on us if we shoot and
like do a jibe at which drivers are no
longer involved but if we were and there
was a child that's that's already I'd
like dead man walking it'll pretty much
his but in black in prison maybe we get
word that somebody's a vacation that
they need to be taken care of because no
child and no matter what it is like or
what who they know as a matter of fact
that's it dick once they hit ground like
and they're not gonna know what's coming
I've you know I've had like six people
just bad stabber just that she came out
you know it should Shahar like
it's sad when like you you can see
things like that and it's normal to it
doesn't it doesn't affect you the way
anymore because you've been sold I think
make people to go to the war you know I
took it the same way like this just in
my workout and I know the best ways to
like go and battle with people about
I can't see that anybody has ever died
from
whatever our dental but I know that the
sailors they always had it coming
it wasn't just because just to do it or
like just you know I mean that's
something me I have to be able to that's
my life if I know I killed somebody or
if I if I know that because of the
things I that's that person that maybe
they my company their whatever you know
and I don't know I've never been told it
like I never been convicted Aphrodite
like evens out that were here I do
it's crazy kid being a mom and being in
the gang life it's been active so to
speak a lot of people will respect the
fact that I I won't do certain things
but my hood
no respect certain things that I choose
not to do it but because I explain to
him whatever it is that I am so
comfortable doing this person because
it's some personal [ __ ] that doesn't
like I love it or respect the fact that
I'm you know now I'm a little more chill
than I was back then I had back then you
know cat people right there right in
front of their face just because I
[ __ ] got mattered or like Jack
somebody just because I know I'm gonna
stick what I [ __ ] it's not it's not
about nothing else except meeting and
what I want at the time that I need it
and
money for my kids or if it's money that
I need to help you know my home with mom
or like anything that it's just I'll
make it happen you know and for me it
I'm because I'm hothead I don't think I
don't think if I just do it
I know what I signed up when I signed up
for you know I wanted all this this is
like I'd drive for that so it's like a
person that [ __ ] addicted to it drugs
it's
um waffle my family for what because
they just
they're there but they're never there
they're not there at all and I had to
get like this if my parents or my dad
whoever gave a [ __ ] about me
really been out there how come they
weren't like those other moms that had
my friends had moms that [ __ ] cooked
for them every day made sure they'd
[ __ ] eat like if they weren't home
they were calling everybody like he's
been up like maybe because they just she
was in her own [ __ ] but either way I
went looking for what I needed I can't
say it was wrong but I can't say like
I'm like an angel you know or nor my
friends but I know that we stand for
something I do and when it comes to my
neighborhood like my brother just treat
them as well would treat my own
if anybody got like crazy one
don't panic I'll be right there with
them and believe it or not the first
time I got down with anybody in my life
was when I go jumped into my head like I
never had a fight before because I don't
know maybe the autofill is just me
holding back like because I don't really
bother nobody but my initiation yeah
this was getting down with two of my own
voice and tomorrow because I guess I was
always wondered yeah oh yeah you get
jumped now it's not jumped but it looks
like that too I mean people they don't
all right but like I mean it's our own
it's our own it's your own version
sisters people that are gonna love you
and and fight for you die for you if I
mean so they have a site they have that
right you know to set you straight
so and me as I think of how to reset
your a lot is because I'm just no
firecracker you know like I don't think
about this but like I don't know I think
when I was like nine
ten-eye you know I got in trouble
because I thought some girl and they
okay so before there but when I was like
9 or 10 I don't think it was really a
fight though like you're a kid you know
but I just had a lot of anger there
cells you can't something I think that's
what fueled me to like wash up on
beaches and just you know like what
would you say what's that like cuz me
I'm I'm I can talk doesn't me wrong I
know how to talk about like I can't talk
when it comes to arguing
I'll start stuttering yeah you look like
a little bit um you know like I'm like
oh you popped out I hear or not I'm like
and I think that's that's what kind of
helps to kind of easy that'll boost you
like stuff that kind of fun
I can't think that lady from the home ec
like [ __ ] that what needs to take off
you know but like I mean I step like I
said this guy for for me personally
because I was I was raised by my father
but my father was there but he wasn't
there and he clothed me he raised me
I'm table but like I just I had I had no
respect for him I feared him and fear
for me now is is like what you do like
what you do you know because I've pretty
much death I danced with therefore I've
take a chance with that everyday you
know I can walk all right now somebody
could do a drive-by to me t-shirts and
we could just be waiting anything happen
but that's that's what he's know my toes
- I I dressed the way I dress
it's the part of me who I am and like
how I how I feel about myself where I
like about how I feel that I know like
I'm the man like give me that song I
feel like the man when you walk do I
feel like I feel like oh the woman when
I walked up like like I had that respect
I know people are gonna die people come
to me be like oh stop he's awful and let
me know what's to give you know and like
all right or they need something people
know they could come to me and he's
gonna play for money for jobs sir wall
like this I'm 38 years old
I've never had a job in my entire life
like I've never worked a nine-to-five
job but one time now and that was this
recent that's twenty eight twenty
nineteen and twenty seventeen like
November's like July August at Toronto
alderman mm I got out of prison and I
had to have I've had my daughter in
prison for the first time I had a
childhood prison and it was [ __ ] up by
like it is what it yeah she started off
in stay W and like she's a little hard
Cohen cuz I don't she's the only one
like I didn't get to I didn't get to be
around because well didn't happen you
know people change in people to someone
sometimes telling know sometimes not
Tanya and then that's another day chip
on my shoulder like oh [ __ ] no like this
one doesn't you know who I am
doesn't you know like doesn't you know
what the [ __ ] out do like he don't know
me very well
I can't want to do that you know one
hurt me but then it's like I mean
he's not worth me [ __ ] having him
take it out or like
whatever I'm doing because he's the
father of my child I would never wanna
do that I would never do that to my
child you know like I want to see the
pain in their eyes because I know what I
did to their father knowing that they're
just kind of learn how not having fun
but like like I could I think I cried
over behind my mom
pollito Thursday to be honest I still do
like every now and then my mom is alive
but my mom is like still gangster
she's still in her cage Judaism
oh she was quick to tell tell us
straight out like a no you guys you guys
are growing it's me and my wife and we
won I mean I like my wife a lot of times
I've had to beat her up twice like she's
[ __ ] put hands on my mom and I'm like
that's not gonna [ __ ] him happy and I'm
from not in front of me especially and
you will respect my mom why because she
she loves you enough to [ __ ] being a
part of our family and that's a lot you
know that cuz we're not just anybody
like that's that's how I feel like my
head like when I just anybody everybody
knows if they know anybody from my head
then I ever had stared if all my homies
right were not strapped we're always
ready for whatever like little little
kids are like 10 years old they're ready
they're just sometimes sometimes we hold
the shows again sometimes we mm-hmm dad
hides again it just depends on what you
know and that's that's the part I
gentlemanlike been enough but it's I'm
gonna adrenaline junkie in for like and
the social aspect of things like I'm on
I'm gonna journal junkie but I get my
journal by possibly getting caught
that's that's I don't know I've always
had that thrill like it said it mixing
it it gives me time children or so no
it's like exciting
s40 escorting I've had to what that us
worry I've one thing is she touch with I
have escorted yeah I had it I had a
choice because I know what I was doing
but I did it because I didn't feel like
I had any other way at that at that time
and I saw that the way sick men would
look at me at at the age that I was and
I was like you know [ __ ] I'm gonna get
this fool I'm gonna fall I said so not
only did I rob them but you know I
[ __ ] got whatever else I felt made me
feel like that was like okay fair I see
no robbery fair exchange but really you
just got got for everything and what are
you gonna say because you were [ __ ]
trying to [ __ ] with a child or like no
kid you know like I think I stabbed just
then I don't know what ever happened to
him I never saw him again but like he
tried like touch me and stuff and and
I just I don't like it it's something it
was like a fear that he gave me I don't
know I guess like the women have the
instinct you know like so he's not safe
something all right and he like grabbed
me in a weird way and I just like looked
up but Tana and so that's why I always
carry something you know like I don't
care I mean I'm not pro us up but then
I'm supposed to having it be like I
don't care no matter what like it might
be on old I'm gonna I'm always gonna
have something on me it doesn't matter
what and you might not know what it is
because I'd rather you not see it coming
if I have to put a bit of razor blade in
my mouth or if I couldn't put in my hair
where every to my fingers like anything
and us being females do you know like
with a play do it real quick no but I
will sort of pull it out on a like on a
hook-up tip you know I know lower men
and then I can just do what I got to do
because I can see the dumbass and he
didn't he's my enemy
and I got a game before you sneeze where
anybody else oh my head thank you very
much